the example that i use is the ways in
which they have deputized
a lot of these local agencies right so
the health department has become an arm
of the government
the osha has become an arm of the
government the labor commissioner has
become an
arm of the government we have been
served complaints
after my little spiel from every single
one of those agencies that i just listed
and when you go back and you try and
utilize the legal process to get to the
basis of those complaints
you find out that they're all political
and that they are utilizing bureaucratic
red tape to try and take out those
people who even
mere question authority in california
part of the weirdness about this was
they kept telling us oh you know just do
take out do takeout and don't go to the
gym so now we're not working out
we're you know most people if you think
take out although you can get all sorts
of stuff
it's like you think about chinese and
pizza and next thing you know we know
that the average person gains something
like eight pounds
in the midst of all of this while while
comorbidities
include diabetes and and being
overweight yeah and one of the things
that i've said throughout
even pre-pandemic and throughout my
career in the food service industry
is it's all about personal right and
when they try
and tell us how many calories we have to
put on the menu or they try and uh
manipulate
what ingredients can go into our food i
always remind local health departments
and those people advocating for those
regulations that look this is about
personal
responsibility and if we try and this
behemoth
uh who's telling who is making decisions
for people
and we lose that personal responsibility
then you know
that's a real dangerous and slippery
slope that we're on and i think that we
saw that
happen throughout the pandemic is that
we went from 10 miles per hour to 60
miles per hour
when it comes to fundamentally altering
the nature of our own personal response
so are you worried that at any given
moment
they could just pull more lockdowns i
mean as we're taping this we're holding
it for a couple days but we're taping
this on april 15th
that is two months to the day of when
gavin newsom says we can fully open he
is now telling us
june 15th there is no science behind
that
magically in two months we can open up
are you worried that okay so
so maybe they do it june 15th although i
remember august 1st remember
that was going to be one of the open ups
way back when but are you worried that
okay they could open us up and then two
days people go out next thing you know
on the 18th here we go again
oh and that will happen yeah i'm not
just worried about it i know it's going
to happen and it's actually
changing the way in which i operate as
an entrepreneur
uh look the pandemic has been the
predicate through which they have
decided they're going to
change the entire system right whether
that's a personal system or whether
that's more of kind of an institutional
system we've seen it
and i know that sounds like
sensationalism but it's the reality of
the situation
now that can be in one person's opinion
that can be changed for the good
in another person's opinion that can be
changed for the bad and perhaps your
middle of the road and you say oh some
changes have been good
some changes have been bad but
nonetheless it's been a massive change
and a fundamental shift
even we hear it today right now suddenly
they want to pack the court with
more supreme court justices right that
is a massive change to the very nature
of our entire constitutional republic
but those changes have set
a new precedent and we're seeing it
especially in the restaurant industry
and the example that i use is the ways
in which they have deputized a lot of
these local agencies right so the health
department has become an
arm of the government the osha has
become an arm of the government the
labor commissioner has become an arm of
the government
we have been served complaints after my
little spiel
from every single one of those agencies
that i just listed and when you go back
and you try and utilize the legal
process to get to the basis of those
complaints
you find out that they're all political
and that they are utilizing bureaucratic
red tape to try and take out those
people who even
mere question authority in california
and that is an incredible did you have
any uh actual one-on-one run-ins with
any of these regulators or health people
or anyone just showing up to your place
shutting you down anything like that oh
yeah oh yeah yeah of course 100
and i've engaged with them and spoken to
them and what i think is really
interesting is they're people just like
the rest of us who want to
collect a paycheck and want to live
their lives um and when you start to
talk to them one-on-one to
really try and understand we had a
health inspector come into the
restaurant
three days after the incident up at
bravery brewing where the lady was
apparently dancing
but you know the the excuse was no i was
drying my hands
you know to the rhythm of um uh air
supply and
that's what the government should be
involved in figuring out if that's true
or not you know
yeah yeah of course of course exactly i
mean don't get me started on that
so so the guy comes in and i said hey
weren't you here a month ago
and he said yeah i said well i'm just
curious why why are you coming in again
he goes oh well you know it was just the
routine inspection and i said no that's
not the routine inspection and then he
immediately says back to me
oh i saw your post about the health
inspector up in l.a
right as if to kind of trip i said what
are your thoughts on that
i would love to have your opinion on
that um and and he gave it to me and he
said well you know i think in la they've
gotten a little bit too stringent on x y
and z
et cetera and he kept it pretty vanilla
but the point being is
i saw that right that is incredibly odd
to me or coincidental
but you know that's just one little
example
um we have been we have been hit with
multiple osha complaints where customers
can just say oh they're not wearing
masks then osha will
give us this complaint and we'll have to
take the time and the opportunity cost
to lay out all the ways in which we are
actually following the rules
et cetera et cetera do you have any
evidence that anyone even got sick at
any of your restaurants at any point
throughout any of this
not only has nobody gotten sick at our
restaurant but we have actually kept
none of our employees have had
significant covet spread we've had maybe
three cases
and i a lot of my contemporaries have
told me about having to wipe out their
entire staff and shut down for good
and people ask me well why is that what
we as
in within the free market we have told
our employees if you even feel the
slightest bit of a sniffle
if you have a friend of a friend of a
friend who contacted somebody with covid
take off do not come to work get a test
we'll pay for we'll pay for all of your
time
time off all of it 100 if it's a month
it's a month
we will pay for all of your cova tests
until you can come back and what that's
done
done is that that's allowed a safety
system within our restaurants whereby
people feel comfortable taking the time
off knowing they're going to get paid
now have we had people take advantage of
that yeah we did two or three people
did we end up getting rid of them for
other reasons anyway or they quit
of course you're always going to have
bad apples but guess what all of our
employees have been good they've all
been healthy
we haven't had spread within the
restaurants because we put that pretty
mandated that we do that
can you talk about how tough it is just
forget cobin for a second like in normal
times the good old days
just how tough it is to to start and
uh continue a successful restaurant
before all of this nonsense
well yeah the biggest issue in the
restaurant industry is is that you
have to have people in order for it to
survive
you cannot automate the restaurant
industry yeah you can put a kiosk up
but you need people to make the food you
need people to input the numbers
so for us it's been about managing
people um
and increasingly over the past five to
ten years what we've seen
is just this crescendo of lawsuits
associated with the people element so
it's become
incredibly risky to even endeavor into
the restaurant space and whether that's
third-party lawsuits slip and fall
lawsuits internal lawsuits the lawsuits
associated with just general human
resources in states like
california new jersey new york what have
you um that the cost of even
doing business is negligible you you
you the only thing that would motivate
you to get into the restaurant industry
is passion
you almost get into it knowing you're
going to lose money and if you break
even you're happy
yeah so speaking of break even you ended
up helping a whole bunch of people
financially in the midst of all this too
when newsome shut down outdoor dining
the second time
it was right after the holidays right
after the
every single news outlet was littered
with photos of people
shopping at black friday sales on top of
one another indoors
at walmart eating burger king with their
mask off or eating a hot dog at costco
with their mask off
in the takeout area i mean it was like
co-ed naked twister
and outdoor dining gets shut down that
was the only bastion of hope for
restaurant tours
in california and they were hiring a lot
going into the holidays so people were
feeling kind of good and then
bam we're going to crush the entirety of
the industry the whole industry is shut
down
oh and by the way california's
unemployment system
is in gridlock because we
misappropriated upwards of 50 to 60
billion dollars to
destitutes poor guys street dwellers
gutter snipes who knows where who knows
what right
we completely left people on the streets
and by we i mean the collective we of
the state of california and newsome said
if we can save one life no you know
there was no message of hope there
right that's where i get frustrated with
newsome so what started to happen with
us is that we were kind of known
in our own local community as an outlet
through which people could get help
if they needed it and people started
reaching out saying i can't pay rent
i can't pay like filed for unemployment
or i'm afraid to file for unemployment
if perhaps maybe they were one of the
undocumented workers let's be honest
right
um and i can't buy any christmas gifts
from my kids as i said
so we said okay well look we've got
people calling up talking about writing
these thousand dollar checks we don't
want to grift for ourselves we'll get by
on our own but why don't we try and
utilize
and galvanize some of the attention that
we're getting raise funds for
all of those restaurant workers that are
struggling right now whether it's 100
the gap for rent
or whether it's 500 to put food and
gifts um you know
under the tree or on the table for the
kids and and you did it and
do you know how many people you helped
or how much you raised or it was like a
whole bunch of different things that you
were doing
yeah well we've raised over four hundred
thousand dollars we've helped over a
thousand families
um we have you know my wife and myself
and my kids i've got four kids
they were driving around with me
dropping checks off to people as far
north as the valley and as far south as
san diego
um it was funny this money starts to
come in first gofundme freezes the money
so we had kind of told people hey you're
approved you applied we looked at your
system all right we looked at all your
references you're good to go and then
there was no money
so then we tried coming out of pocket
wait did they tell did they tell you why
they were
pausing it or shutting you down or no it
was like it
it was a glitch yeah it was a glitch and
we were frozen for about three weeks
so um that was really hard on us because
the donations kept coming in and we
wanted to help people it was in the
holidays time was very
sensitive so eventually it was okay well
now how do we get this money out right
you got limits on zell limits on venmo
limits on cash app all this so it became
we became
we were trying to run eight restaurants
in the midst of the holidays
while we were shut down well we didn't
shut down outdoor dining and my wife
myself and my four kids with a newborn
were driving around southern california
handing checks out to people or to
landlords because in many cases we're
paying people's rent et cetera
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell